So if you take this scenario on the left here,
we see that the mRNA copy is exactly the same
link that is the DNA gene. Well, if this is
true then that means that nothing was spliced out. No
entrons left, in which case we have one xon. We
have one full xon that takes up the whole length
of the gene. Now, on the scenario in the right,
you see that our mRNA copy is in fact shorter than
a DNA gene. So, this does tell us that there's some splicing going on,
and introns are being cut out, and some exons are being retained. But you can
tell that we don't have any demarcation here where the introns and exons are, we
just know that there are some. So we can't determine exactly how many we have.